[Music]
Salam alaikum warahmatullahi oh but I
care - how you guys doing this is just
something I've never done before
actually it's AQ & a session where i'm
looking at some of the questions that
you have put in the community page of
smile - Jenna hang on to your seats ask
him his Bangladeshi fans want to know
will he change the cover picture of his
phone and put a Royal Bengal tiger in it
[Laughter]
maybe why not why not you know if I have
to see if the Bengal tigers extinct to
the last things I collided my big thing
so I'll have to see him ask him how we
young parents are all two can save our
kids from converting into European
Muslims or moderate Muslims I'm gay the
person says I'm getting married very
soon I want to have a lot of kids okay
please don't give me laughs so here's
this end om you give me a lot of stories
and this is written more man this is a
big serious thing one of the greatest
things you can pass on to your children
which I'm having very big difficulty in
doing myself is language okay it's a
serious thing that our parents succeeded
with us especially if you're second
generation in passing one the native
tongue because we are much more
comfortable speaking the English
language this is gonna be an uphill
struggle and sometimes you're gonna need
the grandparents to get involved but try
where we have to try I'm not giving you
advice on this I'm I'm genuinely given
myself advise there to pass on the
language it's a serious serious thing if
you speak or do at home you know this is
a serious language it's a serious
languor do is spoken by I don't know how
many hundreds of million and also think
about the amount of people that speak
Hindi which is a closed language
if you know you're gonna know a lot of
Hindi as well if you speak bangle is a
serious language you know if it's Somali
is a serious language make sure that
that is passed on
you know don't don't honestly do not not
give your children the gift of language
this is just one advisor and this is
advice to me as well what does he thinks
of this means that you put in your video
I like them they're very funny they're
very funny that the ones really that
actually without them the video would be
really a pointless one
a pointless one a frivolous one how can
you answer questions directly and
fluently and what's the best way to give
dower to non-muslims the best way to
give that was not to engage in debate
now and that might sound like
contradictory coming from me or
something but yeah you see me give
debate
dude do debates and stuff that's not
really hard to come to try and conveyed
it the best way the best way to win a
debate is to not the best way to
convince someone is to not get into a
debate with them and try and avoid the
bailout all costs over that person's a
loved one or someone that you meet in
the streets you know genuinely the best
way to win a debate is to avoid one in
the first place and so really we're not
trying to win debates here when you're
speaking to a non-muslim you're just
giving them informative statements about
what Islam is and what and the biggest
bestower is just straightforward it's
non philosophical which say we believe
in one God this and that the basic like
tenants a lot of people will just accept
it you don't have to go into depth we
only do that to show that we can do that
of all due respect we can we can do that
we can get involved
Islam is a very simple religion but it
can get very complex and it has answers
to very many complex questions and
that's what our engagements with people
on on that level it tries to show it's
not to show that Islam is not simple
because it is most importantly ask him
how he deals with negative negativity
from speaker's corner and at the same
time have a peaceful heart I don't know
if I do have a peaceful unfortunately I
I think that it's definitely moving in
for direction now I have had it in the
beginning if you look at my videos in
2017 and see the evolution the more I'm
challenged the more I become more rough
and and to be honest I'm not the best
person to seek for advice I need to get
I've asked myself because sometimes the
best thing is to move away from the
whole thing you know and and what I
realized more and more is that we need
to think about going back to Allah
making tawba I'm making repentance
because how else will our hearts become
soft the Quran says Allah me at needle
Adina amino and Tasha bloom lyrically
leahy you know is it not time now for
the for those who believe for them to
have or in their hearts am in listening
to the reminder of Allah woman as a
lemon al-haq you know and from what has
revealed been sent down to them and not
to be like those who came before them
for cassettes Pulu boom ok Theo Moonves
a hoon and they had their hearts became
very hard and a lot of them are forsook
for offensive horn that a lot of them
evil do it so this idea of having a
clean and beautiful heart which is what
the Quran says your Malayan foul melon
will a balloon in lemon at Aloha
behold bin Salim the day where you need
to come to Allah with a basically
rectified her be a pile been selling so
this the rectification of heart is
something I haven't even embarked upon
it properly in order to to comment on it
effectively his thoughts on being an
Arab living in quasi Dessie country I
don't think it Israel is ethics you I
think here you may be this guy'll ism or
was it Bradford but believe me I know
you know I mean I like it I like all
cultures are like multiculturalism you
know when I go to Egypt some that's one
thing I do miss I miss the multicultural
nature of just this place asked him by
his personal life like as you
where he learnt to use those big words
that shocked the people other than
mashallah
other than that masha'Allah there's
actually a book I think is written by
something something called something Bly
it's a book called smart words for the
intellectuals or something like that
a camera to make you sounds big words to
make you sound smart or something it's
an interesting book I've been looking
for it just to get someone plucking out
some words then because words are like
you know ammunition you know if you have
the right words they can make people
laugh they can make people cry they can
make people angry like a baby
so words seriously words are a great
obviously vehicle for communication so
and the good old the source I mean why
not you know just use the source and try
and pick out some words but you you know
reading books and then kind of
underlining key words putting him in a
notepad of some sorts and then defining
them late in your time in your own time
what language does he speak was his
favorite one so I speak English in
Arabic there's other things I'm trying
to learn bomb like I'm gonna pretend to
list them here what's the favorite one
oh I'm more fluent in English anything
else oh I'm a three-layer interracial
marriage advice and tips especially for
resistant families best way to seek
education while being a full-time
student Oh Islamic education well okay
I'll give you one piece of advice on the
second part of question is make use of
your travel time that's a big one
you can memorize the whole Quran on your
way to universe and coming back yes it's
very possible so that's one piece of
advice that's very practical that you
can go and do now how to give down to X
Muslim atheist please just as you would
give down to any other person you know
it just give them the go wrap it's
called to go wrap research what the go
wrap is and you will see when he when
will he finally stop talking about how
tall he is I don't know what I don't
know when I was really making videos
about that one brother
I smoke I smell a jealousy there's a
jealous jealous tragic I wish you know
compute engine but I want to do down
what do you recommend me to study during
my college my college study to start
with no no memorize Quran and try
understand what that means
just a few pathetic you know just limit
yourself to that and also like I said
you before basics of kam [__] and aji de
those three things is enough to keep you
occupied obviously Arabic language as
well it's enough to keep you occupied
with your work believe me
how does he feel after defeating David
wood very good very good
have you ever had Somali food yes he's
very good as berries when Holub and you
know moors and you know you know what i
mean all of those things that I enjoyed
a bit of that and I know you know mhm
that's right tell him that he's finished
then challenge him to anyway if I saw
your question is a [__] show the hijab
means that ask him to which is his
favorite I've done I have to think about
how to have a better mindset that's a
good question
you know part of the religion of Islam
is to be very optimistic there's
actually many a hadith like that and I
can enumerate them for you in another
time but that's just optimism and
connected to a lot of paratime and one
Hadees that the Prophet my source
alarmingly high school teachers I am the
opinion of my slave so if he thinks good
of me then he'll get good in other words
if you have an optimistic attitude
especially in relation to allah subhanaw
taala allah will reward you and give you
good for that attitude and a personal
Quran will ensure Khartoum lies either
neck um if you were thankful Allah won't
give you more so this is these are two
things I just wanted to see his reaction
to old
what you are dirty except for clips of
you okay that's I hope you ask him for
that ask him how he controlled himself
when he read one point someone during
the debate you know I just think of the
consequences and I'm not the best I
country like sometimes I can control my
anger to a good level and sometimes that
card and I think you guys know when
one asked him to speak or do with you no
no no I'm not gonna embarrass myself in
that manner please ask him to do Q&A is
often on his channel next okay well hey
I'm doing that now what are the best
books resources to understand origins of
liberalism feminism comprehensively so
liberalism you're gonna have to stop in
basic start with secondary sources and
then he goes their primary ones that's
my basic basic advice but I think this
is gonna require another video okay
genuinely Western in Islamic philosophy
and history as well so I've kind of
covered that in the beginning but we do
need to go into that in detail on that
ask him how he feels
let's turn into a meme I wasn't
intentional that's usually how these
things go when I would like while we're
getting a haircut
I'm thinking of actually growing hair a
little bit you know I know this
controversial opinion but you know so I
do I want you know and this in his life
and just like him you know hello Sally
Mally Kamara not Allah he what I get
you